it's a hilarious movie it's so much fun  and I know you guys have tapped into  your own experiences as the Lonely  Island but did you kind of tap into our  Canadian boy Justin Bieber  I thought you say Mike Myers yeah we're  hoping the tap Maury you want to have  more into my question Carrie be careful  they're great yeah but Justin Bieber was  he part of Ken Conner for real a little  terrified not any more or less than  anyone else like not any more or less  than you know Katy Perry Katy Perry yeah  watching all those document that popu  memories like one direction this is a  sim capability and the JLo one and a few  Beyonce ones and kind of pulled from  everything